yesterday I reported to you that the Donald
Trump campaign did some internal polling in
a number of key battleground states and that
Donald Trump currently according to his own
campaigns, internal polls is losing some major
important 2016 brat battleground states to
most, if not all likely democratic challengers
in hypothetical.
Um, a one on one match ups.
Trump's reaction, as I told you yesterday
was Barry, the polls say we're doing great.
Period.
Now, unfortunately at the same time that Donald
Trump's campaign was doing internal polling
and a lot of these battleground states, other
regular upholsters, we're also doing polls
in those battleground states and the public
polls say the exact same thing.
Donald Trump is not doing particularly well
right now in one on one match ups in a number
of key states, including Wisconsin and Michigan
and Pennsylvania and others.
Now, Donald Trump has been presented with
the public polls showing that he's currently
losing to every major 2020 Democratic candidate
in these hypothetical 2020 matchups and Trump
has absolutely lost it and is now claiming
that the polls are totally fake.
Donald Trump tweeting and a to tweet tweet
storm quote, the fake news has never been
more dishonest than it is today.
Thank goodness we can fight back on social
media.
There are new weapon of choice is fake polling,
capital F in fake capital P in polling, sometimes
referred to as suppression Poles.
They suppress the numbers had it in 2016 but
this is worse.
The fake corrupt news media said they had
a leak into polling done by my campaign, which
by the way, and despite the phony and neverending
witch hunt are the best numbers we have ever
had.
Lie, lie, lie.
I mean this is all lies.
They reported capital f fake numbers and then,
uh, that they made up and don't even exist.
All caps, we will win again.
Now, there are people on the left who actually
agree with Trump that the polls are totally
fake and they email me daily and they'd tell
me, Joe Biden's not really winning.
The Democratic primary.
Bernie is actually ahead of Biden or Tulsi
is actually pulling 10% not 1% you can't believe
anything that's there.
Now, I've already talked about what is and
isn't accurate about polling, but the polls
are not fake.
Okay?
If your evidence is we know 2020 polls are
fake because 2018 poles were totally wrong
and fake, and 2016 poles were totally wrong
and fake.
Well, the 2016 national polls were correct.
They had Hillary winning by two or three points
nationally, and she did.
Of course she lost the electoral college ultimately
because of the 77,000 votes in three states
that were within the margin of error.
But the national polls were right in 2016
the national polls were basically right in
2018 as well in terms of what would happen
in the Senate with Democrats and Republicans
and what would happen in the house with Democrats
and Republicans.
So I don't know what that contingent of the
left is referring to.
I don't know what Trump is referring to a
because what is now publicly being said in
these polls is the exact same thing that Donald
Trump's own internal polls, these battleground
states are saying, and specifically Donald
Trump, I'm guessing, is referring to a new
Quinnipiac poll from this week.
We're Donald Trump is losing to every leading
2020 democrat.
Let's put the results up on the screen.
Trump versus Biden, Biden 53 Trump 40 Sanders,
51 Trump 42 that's plus nine for Bernie.
Camilla Harris at 49 Trump 41 that's plus
eight for Camila Warren, 49 to 42 over Trump.
That's plus seven booted judge and Cory booker
both 47 to 42 plus five over Donald Trump.
So normal caveats here.
Number one, is it likely that Donald Trump
will end up with only 40 or 41% of the vote
in the 2020 election?
No, Donald Trump is going to get more unless
there's a serious third party challenger,
Trump's going to get more than 40 or 41% there
are some undecideds in those numbers that
are ultimately going to vote, most likely
for either Trump or the Democratic challenger.
There hasn't been a, is it likely Trump will
lose the popular vote by seven eight nine
10 13 even as a, uh, being shown in the Quinnipiac
poll?
Absolutely not.
There has not been a popular vote margin of
10 or greater in a presidential election since
Ronald Reagan 35 years ago and it would be
very unlikely to happen in 2020.
But the main takeaway here, the point is Trump's
not doing well right now, 17 months from the
election in a number of battleground states
and nationally against hypothetical Democratic
presidential nominees who we don't even actually
know who is going to be the nominee.
Yeah, there's even a poll.
This is amazing.
There's a poll showing Trump down to Joe Biden
in Texas by four points, which is very close
to Trump's net favorability in Texas, which
is minus three, meaning three percentage points
more.
Uh, see Trump unfavorably in Texas, then favor
oily favorably.
But I want to, every time we do polling stuff,
I'm going to go back to this because it's
so important and I apologize.
The people who say, I've said this enough,
I can't possibly say it enough.
I want to caution everyone to be very careful
here.
We actually want Trump to think that he's
winning because if Donald Trump really thinks
the polls are fake, uh, maybe he really does
believe that he's currently winning in these
head to head match ups.
That's what we want because a Trump who thinks
he's winning and that he has it in the bag
hopefully won't actually go out and campaign.
And I'll hang around the White House and he'll
play golf and he'll send weird tweets out
and that will make it more likely that he
ultimately will lose in 2020 it's really important
to understand that we want to on the one hand,
not take for granted, no matter what the polls
say, you as an individual voter should operate
under the belief that your vote could swing
the election to or away from Trump in your
state.
Okay?
And if you take that approach, what you would
do on election day or as soon as early voting
starts in your state is you would go and you
would vote.
So no matter what the polls say, assume operate
under the guise that your vote could make
the difference.
That's number one.
Number two, when it comes to what Trump thinks
about polls, the better Trump thinks he's
doing, the less he's going to campaign, the
less seriously.
He's going to take the possibility that he
gets defeated in 2020.
And we have to remember systemically, we are
at a disadvantage.
Gerrymandering favors Republicans, number
one.
Number two, the urban rural divide favors
Republicans in conjunction with the Electoral
College.
Number three, uh, when we consider all of
the different possible types of interference
that Donald Trump said to George Stephanopoulos
yesterday, he would welcome in 2020 in terms
of opposition research or oppo research has
Trump calls it a against potential Democratic
candidates.
There's a whole bunch of stuff systemically
stacked against us, the voter suppression
tactics that they will continue to, to employ.
So the better Trump thinks he's doing, the
less likely it is he will take action that
might actually help them in 2020.
And that's something we shouldn't forget either.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Follow me while you're there at David.
Dot.
Pacman.
Lots of great behind the scenes pictures from
my trip to Los Angeles last week and a lot
of other great stuff to do.
We'll take
quick break and be back right after